[Music]
i'm talina kopien i'm co-founder of
purse rehab we're a family-owned company
we've been in business for 35 years i'm
going to walk you through how my team
restores a 2 000
louis vuitton belt back that's been
slashed it's from their 2003 collection
so it's discontinued our client reached
out to us unfortunately this was part of
an argument with an ex-boyfriend who
decided to slash her favorite bag
the repair process will entail several
steps
what we have here is our senior
technician disassembling the front
pocket of the bag from the main zipper
compartment and this is done by undoing
the stitching that's on the outermost
layer
and what we're using here is a round awl
to open up the stitches it's important
to use a round awl because this will
help with not damaging the canvas
once we've taken apart the front pocket
we will move on to the main lining and
we will undo the stitching there to
remove the piping which is basically
what's keeping the front pocket and the
main compartment together and again we
will be using the same round all to do
this step
once we're done with the deconstruction
phase we will be replacing the following
pieces that have the most damage the
front pocket which includes the lining
and the lining that is also part of the
main compartment which is outer facing
so the three layers will be replaced
here we're recreating the pieces that
we're going to replace and we do this by
making templates to match the exact size
of the original piece that we're
replacing we're using a sharp knife to
cut out the template we have three
different pieces that we'll be doing so
this is an important part of the
replacement process to ensure that we
get the exact same template that matches
the original piece
we are using authentic recycled louis
vuitton material we have the canvas that
we'll be replacing with an authentic
piece that matches the original and we
are also using the lining from a
recycled bag that matches the existing
lining
so in essence we are using the exact
same type of material to restore the
pieces that we are replacing
here our senior technician is skiving
the canvas
skiving is a process where the leather
or canvas is thinned out it's
essentially shaved to a thinner layer
and it's typically only done around the
edges because those are the areas that
we're going to fold and stitch
once the canvas is skived our technician
here is applying glue to the area that
was skived and we're using a plastic
container with a pointy tip to ensure
that the glue is only applied to the
area that we need to apply to
[Music]
we have applied the glue now we'll be
putting the lining together with the
canvas that we recreated and we apply
the heat because the heat helps activate
the glue so that it adheres better and
it's secure
once we've completed this step we're
going to stitch the louis vuitton
monogram piece that we are reusing this
is the original piece
that we're restitching on the lining
that we cut out so the lining is new but
the top portion is the existing piece
so once we restitch this together
we will bring the front pocket and the
back lining
together once the two pieces have been
separately stitched
we will glue them together using contact
cement glue we need to glue every piece
before we do the stitching to ensure
there's no movement
and it's very secure
and once we have the front pocket and
the back lining together we are going to
put in the date code this is an
important piece to retain the
authenticity of the bag
once that's done the next step is to
re-glue the piping to the trim of the
front pocket again here we're reusing
the same piping
because it wasn't damaged and we want to
retain as much of the original parts as
possible
after gluing the piping we're going to
restitch to the front pocket you'll
notice that the piping has two stitch
lines one is to stitch the piping to the
front pocket and the second line is to
stitch it to the main compartment
the next step here is to patch up the
interior lining cut we did not replace
the full interior lining in an effort to
retain the original pieces because it
wasn't very damaged and it's a less
visible space we're using a wider brush
to apply the glue because we're working
with wider space so we don't have to be
as precise
we're now gluing the main compartment to
the exterior pocket
and we are stapling the two pieces
together this is not something that's
typically done in this industry but our
senior technician has been using this
technique for many years and it's a
successful technique because it's
basically an added layer of security to
ensure that there's zero movement when
we're stitching all the pieces together
and he's hammering down the staples to
ensure that they're flat and there's no
chance of them being caught in the
sewing machine when we do the stitching
and we're using a guide to ensure that
the stitching is straight and aligned
with the bag
and here we are removing the staples
using a stapler remover and this is a
rounded tip so it doesn't cause any
damage to the bag
we're hammering the edges of the bag
after turning it right side out to
straighten out the edges and ensure
everything is in place
of course we have to straighten out the
piping to make sure everything is in
place so that the final stitching will
be as perfect as possible
we have to be very careful in this
particular stage to ensure that the
needles
go back into the same hole so we have to
be very focused and very careful in
making sure that we are using not only
the same color thread the thickness of
the thread has to match and we follow
the holes accordingly
i'm super pleased with the results and
so proud of our team and our senior
technician for taking this challenge on
and giving this bag a second life i
can't wait to share it with our client
[Music]